what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today we're going
to talk about the whole fresh and fit
situation before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
while you're at it
comment below what i should react to
next
so um this is gonna be like an overview
for people that don't know so fresh and
fit
they run like a a show every night where
they have like girls come on the show
and they talk about different topics and
recently they've been getting a lot of
backlash for
this clip some play it
which are traits of feminine women
what's her gram what's your strengths
yeah that's crazy i ain't gonna like
just keep it real
i don't really date black girls
it's not because like no no like like
most black girls are like annoying how
to put this a ratchet and they don't
know how to like be reserved you're like
the complete opposite you are not the
stereotype you are not the stars you're
not the same that's awesome yeah so i'll
we'll give you that compliment what's
your question
um it's crystal fit
okay so when i when i look at this stuff
i always try to put myself in someone
else's shoes
now if someone said to me
i don't usually date gingers right i've
got the you could say white girls i just
feel like gingers
it's more close to home they're usually
annoying
ugly
awkward
unattractive i don't know something like
that i don't
know what stereotypes
i just i don't take [ __ ] personal i just
don't care and i
know i know this is a you know touchy a
touchy subject okay
but if someone doesn't want to date me i
just don't take it personal because i
would i'll just date someone else
like i don't you only need to find one
person that wants to date you now
this kind of goes into the question like
is there a stereotype with black girls
now i'm not gonna say if there is or
there isn't because
to be honest like i grew up in a pretty
white
neighborhood um
but
if i'm being honest like i've heard that
for like because i i've dated black guys
like uh my last two boyfriends were
black
and that's very common to be honest like
i've had a lot of guys tell me that
and do i think it's true that's the next
question
i don't think the majority of black
girls are like that like if i meet 10
black girls i don't think the majority
is
like that
however
i've had enough guys tell me that that i
have a hard time believing like guys
that don't know each other at all
that i have a hard time believing it
came from nothing and i think it's very
arrogant of me as like a white girl to
say
you you you you
don't have any idea what you're talking
about
um
and it also kind of like speaks to what
type of black girls they deal with like
the black girls in my church are
actually like super feminine super like
fit feminine friendly all the [ __ ] that
like they ideally want but you have to
understand like those are the circles
they run in
so okay
then this is the next clip so then i
guess
i want to pull up the britney runner
interview but i think it's going to get
like copyright strikes
um ellie
stop my dog
um
i i can't pull it up i don't think i
should hopefully this doesn't get
copyright struck either but let's see so
then they go on this podcast to like
talk about their views a lot of this
[ __ ] is just childish which is fine if
you want to be funny we just talk about
how doctors ain't [ __ ] for 45 minutes we
are not in any way life coaching we are
not in any way trying to help men
outside of hey come have a laugh for a
couple hours if you're gonna paint
yourself as life coaches and then say
[ __ ] like yeah you know i mean i just
don't really [ __ ] with black girls i
guess i guess my mic is
maybe this is a hundred percent possible
that i just
don't see their point of view because
they're not talking about me
but i've had guys tell me they'd rather
date a black girl like
like the the dude i i was like that you
know broke my heart he left me and dated
a black girl
like
i've had guys tell me that
and
especially if you have you're not dating
them at all who cares like i do not care
who myron and fresh hook up with it's
not gonna be me
like it's that it's not me so who gives
a [ __ ] who they want to date i think
it's more like their tone where they're
like oh most of them are annoying or
whatever like probably most of the ones
they deal with because
to be honest i watched their show most
of the girls in their show are annoying
like
i went on their show i was one of them
just curious me i'm not like other girls
that's what they make fun of us i'm just
curious it's like where does preference
come from like i was trying to think
about this after i saw the clip and i
was just like why do i like what i like
i don't know why do i like what i like i
like
i like tall black guys and skinny white
boys i don't know what it is those are
my two types
and i don't meet asian guys that are
taller than me but asian guys are cute
too i don't really discriminate to be
honest
yeah and i really was thinking about
that like who's
who decides that is it
my life is it my surroundings like if i
was raised in mexico i'm sure i would
find mexican girls beautiful i would eat
mexican food like these would be my
preferences but preferences aren't
really choices right culture dictates
our preferences i think the experiences
also i want to say what you've been
raised on what you've been taught
because for example i'm from the islands
right barbados yeah yeah so i've seen
mainly black women my whole life now
when it came to like taurus girls i was
like wow
white girls are here in barbados lit i
don't i want to see what's going on yeah
i give it a try like it's pretty dope
yeah you know it's two different
cultures so for me okay let me try
something new see how how it is yeah and
i'm here in the states is like okay
spanish girls white girls girls from all
over the world are bad however regarding
black women per se like dude like my
thing is like
we're in a space where like people are
targeted especially the black people per
se black white yeah and it's like
whatever you say can be used to the
extreme so what we said was kind of like
i want to say uh not funny to them but
tell us it's like we're just talking
jokes trying to be you're being
hyperbolic about your dating preferences
yeah right that's kind of how i took it
to be honest with you but i think a lot
i think you can understand how the
internet might have taken it right and
and then doubling down and being like
it's okay to have this as a preference
that you yeah again i don't think people
were mad that they said they dated that
type of person i think people were more
mad because
like the way they said it almost like oh
they're so annoying
and
gosh i
i hate to ellie what are you doing in my
room come here
come here
i hate that people always have to have
that oh but it's not all like
why do we even have to discuss that like
it's clearly not all
like i like that be the stupidest thing
to say oh all black girls are this like
duh
like you see
some of the prettiest girls i've ever
seen have been black
and like feminine too like i'm telling
you boy this girl in my church she got
married
super young like she was stunning she
was so feminine like more feminine than
i'll ever be
so it's like a stupid argument to say
all but
like why do we live in this culture
where we always have to preface not all
i don't know but again i know nothing my
opinion means nothing this is just my
thoughts as i'm watching this like
usually your preference is what you like
not what you don't exactly i think that
was the biggest issue like if you're
just like hey my preferences are kind of
like latinas i don't even think you get
any pushback but saying my preference is
i don't like that
that's i think where people start to
feel rejected and then
yeah that's the thing like people take
it personally because they're like oh
you won't date me like guys
do you think the beauty standard is a
six foot ginger
do you think that's
like a pale six foot ginger
it's not the beauty standard like i i
dead lift close to 300 pounds
like that's not the ideal i think it's a
girl that like
does ballet it is like a 5-5 brunette
you know i've had so many guys tell me
they like tan girls
what i can't
who cares don't date them oh my gosh
they go why why don't you like me man
like also the way they said they didn't
like it and this is for everyone always
says i'm so biased with fresh and fit
videos
so
that's that's what i
was like bothered by the clip it's like
you guys go out of your way to say what
you don't like even though that's not
what you're discussing it's like your
preference is what you do like but then
the way in which you went about how you
don't like black women oh i don't like
the ratchet i don't like the ghetto i
don't like the shaniquas like that's
like if you a white person saying all
that that's racist also feel free to see
that sound board right there i want to
buy it
so send a donation to the channel
because then if i if i get that sound
board it's about 500 bucks i don't have
the money right now
i'll be able to bring girls on from my
team they're literally international
like they'll be such cool conversations
so this is [ __ ]
and i'm just disappointed in you guys as
black men to be talking about our
sisters like that
so you don't have a problem with the way
you spoke about your sisters like that
like if that if it was him saying the
same thing
you would be upset
no
no he was like oh i don't like ghetto
black women i don't like shaniqua i
wouldn't want to buy them that's the
preference because because the thing is
is that that's lame
the only thing i can control is my
reactions to what happens in the world
like the world yeah it's not a fun it's
not like a rosy place where everyone is
gonna not be biased or not be a racist
or whatever like i understand that
there's gonna be people that are
inherently racist it is what it is and
the only thing i can control is my
emotions to it so i don't get mad about
what people say because and i just
i'm so sorry i i know this is going to
sound so insensitive i just don't care
if people don't want to date me
i've been rejected my whole life
my whole life
i've had a lot of noses sorry
that's just the way things are i don't
the world doesn't owe me
understanding so all i don't do is real
quick real quick you know what's weird
is like so the word racism
thrown out like i don't i never saw it
as racist because
i don't know i did i didn't i didn't
believe
that you guys wouldn't date a beautiful
black woman yeah
yeah like i just didn't believe that
and again you guys can correct me but
like for me
the word like preference is so weird
because
i think our preferences are really like
mechanisms
that we use to find like emotional
security you know like if if if if a
person's like super quiet like if i'm
like this quiet like shy dude my
preference is probably an aggressive
girl because she allows me to be in my
safe place right i don't have to go like
out of my way to go get her and i'll
probably
prefer
that girl but it's not based on like
this chemistry thing it's really based
on like what allows me to feel like
emotionally secure right and like let's
say i'm i'm a controlling ass dude i
probably want a girl that is a little
bit more like in need of guidance
because yeah submissive because then i
get to feel my safe place which is
controlling right so like i feel like if
a girl and again i can't speak for y'all
but i feel like if a girl
gave you that emotional security
regardless of what race they were
you guys would date yeah i i genuinely
think they would date a black girl if
they thought she was hot fit feminine
friendly they'd absolutely date her get
out
i can't feel like just because they're
they're black you would say no like i
know there's a girl in my church i think
she's married now but she was like 21 a
virgin stunning
you're not you wouldn't date her
yeah here's the thing about the clip
like i said it's context it's us having
a good time it's us making jokes we make
fun of everyone it's just that they
don't clip all the other segments of us
making jokes on everyone else they want
to clip that one sec that one section at
20 30 seconds say that you know try to
paint a narrative you guys are racist
and because you guys are racist this is
why you kicked it racial yeah guys he
was he was rude to me when i was on his
show
i'm a
i'm the whitest girl on earth he's rude
to me guarantee he's rude to everybody
guys that's like that's their brand
respectfully i don't think right i never
said that the racist i don't but i'm
just saying what they're doing that's
fine
i know people who know you they say
you're good guys stand up guys so i
don't have a problem with you as people
yeah otherwise i wouldn't have you on
this podcast and then you know what i
mean like yeah sure you can never give
up or whatever but i'm curious this
isn't
racist i mean literally curious to have
the conversation it doesn't bother me
that i think it's not racist it's
self-loathing which to me i don't
particularly give a [ __ ] how any other
race looks i don't
am i self-loathing because i've dated
black guys mostly
is that am i self-loathing
but i still would i'd still like
i'm discriminate you know
except us i give a [ __ ] how we look at
ourselves so if i saw indian saying some
[ __ ] like that that would bother me
andrew told me he didn't like indian
girls all the time that's great don't
date them that's good for me but when an
indian says that [ __ ] then it's like yo
you do that because you say you don't
like white women
i know i know i know and there's this
stuff but isn't that divorced my wife
and [ __ ] a lot of indian chicks
but i have a problem with somebody that
i feel is self-loathing and i'm not
going to be as offended because you're
not from where i'm from but if i was
black and because i was alex i'd be like
yo that [ __ ] is
more than racist is self-loathing and
that bothers me what do you guys think
about that
like do you guys so let's remove the
racism thing here yeah what about do you
think it has anything to do with
self-loathing is there any like kind of
like internalized
hatred
look at myron's face
he's like no
he's like i love myself like this might
not even be your fault it might be like
the surroundings you were in and made
you feel like these girls
weren't good enough for you
uh i would say honestly bro like this
experience man like yeah for example
like you said earlier if my girl is like
feminine submissive and like black i
could date her and like in the past like
i told you yeah party she was the only
black girl there i was dating her so it
was like it's not i hate black men it's
more like
experience shows me that hey for
whatever reason like you know um if i
find somebody with those traits i'll
date them so so this is interesting a
buddy of mine and we have different
opinions on it you know oh we'll go i
want to hear yours yeah i don't know i
mean it's just
like
what i'm saying is that like it's not
our normal preference as in like it's
not what i normally date but if i was if
you were to take 10 girls that i've
dated in the past maybe one or two of
them would be would be black right you
know what i'm saying it's not the normal
thing i go for and as far as like me
being offended if someone were to say
something about a race or whatever like
i said i wouldn't personally be offended
by it you know i
like we make jokes on everyone so it's
like hey man we make fun of asian girls
white girls again i don't have an issue
with the jokes i have an issue with the
mentality yeah it's yeah
that's not a mentality
the joke to me you were talking to a guy
who's made the craziest jokes death
threats from everywhere i don't i can
separate myself and be like that's a
joke that failed that's not but i think
i think the issue is
it's like it's basically you're saying
you're
stereotyping all black girls
it's not that you won't date them it's
the stereotype it's like you you think
this way about black girls
and
how do i put it like it it is a
stereotype but
like i just think that's such a dumb
of course they don't mean all black
girls like duh there's beautiful
feminine fit black girls i meet them all
the time
like i don't
yeah i just
it's like i feel like a lot of times as
a society like we clearly know what
they're talking about we clearly know
they don't mean everyone and yet we
still like get mad
and make them clarify
would you date a black girl like duh i
don't know i wire eggs
i think i'm just
i i don't like to say i'm not like other
girls i just don't get offended that
easily like i just don't care
i don't know for sure i just want you
guys to understand where the the
reaction yeah i probably weigh more
than most girls they've dated
don't don't date me i don't care comment
sorry because i think mabel better and
help you no we understand we understand
so it's not the jokes it's literally
just
feeling like you don't date a specific
group of people and they're trying to
understand
i think that's what it is because i
think what you said is probably the most
honest which is yeah if this girl meant
all the things that i like in a woman
and she was black obviously dater but i
don't know if you feel the same way no
no if she met my requirements and her
skin tone is relevant but what i'm
saying is that
most of the time you know most of the
girls that i've dated right just didn't
fit that part the most like fit feminine
friendly girls i've met that are black
i've been in the church
so here's here's the thing like my buddy
right now who's trying to find a jewish
girl right he might be in this room and
he's trying so hard to find a jewish
girl and he just found latin jewish
girls
and he goes oh my god they got the whole
latin thing
and they're jewish and now all of a
sudden the latin thing is kind of like a
preference right they're so sexy they're
so intimate there's like a spicy real
connection now there's nothing wrong
with you saying i like the latin thing
right now you're putting that affect on
all latin women which is not necessarily
the case but you want a latin girl who
is jewish
right so is it possible to put a
cultural affect on a race maybe when you
guys were speaking about
race
is it possible to put a cultural affect
on a race yeah
i mean guys black is such that's such a
big group of people
like there are so many subsets of black
people like
i really like
like i've met guys in the in america
that are nigerian and i kind of have a
thing for them because they like are
always really hard working and like
i don't know they always work really
hard and like have similar values to me
and that's a subset of people that are
black but like
you also meet black guys that are so you
know
different than that
and you can't
you clearly can't categorize
an entire group of people but you can
talk about a subset
but it's not it's a joke it's not like a
academic conversation you know
like oh my gosh
i don't know you guys could tell me if
you think i'm wrong
you're like seriously let me know in the
comments
i don't i'm not like
fans of fresh and fit like i said i
wouldn't go on their show again
so if anyone's unbiased on this it's me
you are really speaking about a cultural
thing because if you made a girl from
lagos nigeria they might act completely
different than a girl that you're
meeting from south florida a girl that
you meet from california a black girl
etc yeah and like you have to understand
like the girls that are coming on their
show are like
girls that have nothing to do during the
week
like because it goes at like one two in
the morning
like it goes to like four sometimes like
clearly you don't don't got a lot going
on
and that's me i was on their show like
there's not going to be this monolith
amongst black with women right um
i would say oh no i would say both of
you where your raise will determine how
how you act for the most part right so
caribbean girls differ from girls from
the us versus like nigeria so
it's called it's culture man honestly
yeah yeah
which of you
yeah i mean like i said
her
we're look i'm looking for certain
traits first and then obviously you know
her race is irrelevant if she meets her
matches so that's
that's like all i needed to hear
okay
they said the same thing
they don't care
as long as she meets the certain traits
they're talking about a specific subset
of black girls
now is it true or is it not true
i don't i don't really have a strong
opinion on this because to be honest
i grew up around white people mostly
like i did not grow up in diverse areas
i grew up in
diverse cultural areas where i lived
with like germans like i spent a lot of
time in different countries uh my
parents hired a lot of indian people
like culturally i grew up very diverse
but like
we didn't we didn't
i grew up in the suburbs man
so
but
i i've had heard a lot of guys talk
about that so the question is
is there any truth to it
and there probably is some truth to it
if this many guys say the same thing
but does it doesn't mean all of them
like clearly no
you know like i've
anyways i think i've made my point
clearer hopefully let me know in the
comments don't forget to subscribe okay
ring the notification bell and i'll talk
to you guys next time and consider
sending a donation to the channel so i
can get that soundboard
thank you